welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
the ability to identify a solution from
among a range of challenges and options
is just one of the career advantages
that temper grads are known for one
example is the management of innovation
and product development track where
business students work with engineering
and design graduate students to develop
prototypes and market entry plans for
actual corporate product launches the
management of innovation and product
development track is a track within the
within the business school that allows
students to take courses in design
engineering with a focus on marketing
and organizational behavior within the
business school when they go into the
workplace they'll have an advanced
knowledge of how to collaborate across
these disciplines and work in an
integrated fashion people say engineers
work different than MBAs and desires
work different than MBAs and they do but
you don't realize how differently think
until you work with them the companies
have patented products that have come
out of the course it's been very
successful in really a great example of
what can happen when you bring together
bright minds from different disciplines